jim jalce et bonjour merci d'être avec
nous comme chaque semaine et on va
commencer par parler de l'ump on va
parler un peu l'ump voilà oui on n'a pas
parlé encore pas encore et il ya un
débat qui monte à l'ump justement ce
moment c'est le débat sur le futur nom
du parti le parti qui va être lancée le
30 mai dit on il ya les jeux d'été qui
sait le 30 mai c'est sur le jdd s'est
amusé interrogeait des politiques de
tous bords sur leurs propositions de
noms j'aimerais que vous réagissiez à
quelques quelques propositions
or la première elle est plutôt
consensuel c'est celle de patrick
balkany ont parlé justement c'est le
rassemblement bon voilà plutôt
consensuel vous en pensez quoi
on l'avait proposé un certain nombre
d'ailleurs de dire le rassemblement ou
de trouver un moyen de mettre le nom de
la france mais en le l'expression est
déjà bloqué donc par définition peut pas
le reprendre
et deuxièmement je pense que pour l'
aile centriste de l'ump
ça fait un peu rpr quoi donc c'est donc
une proposition qui va certainement
beaucoup moins vous plaire c'est celle
de florian philippot le rien pour
rassemblement des inutiles et des nantis
ça vous inspire un commentaire que tout
ce qui est excessif est vain et et
florian philippot serait mieux inspiré
de s'occuper du front national ps
également qu'il fait les dernières
propositions du ps lui rp pour union en
recharge de projets que leur répondez
vous ce pauvre c'est l'hôpital qui se
fout de la charité c'est franchement vu
le niveau zéro du ps ils sont gentils
mais eux aussi s'occupe d'eux plus
sérieusement il ya un nom kick on
entendait les d'un de ces derniers jours
c'est l'airé les républicains est ce que
vous confirmez que ce noël est à l'étude
qui pourrait nous confirment qu'il est à
l'étude et qui tourne je dis pas que ce
sera finalement retenu ça on verra bien
ce que le bureau politique décidera le
moment venu mais
c'est vrai que les républicains ça
tourne beaucoup et ça vous plaît mais
moi je suis républicain donc ça me va
bien
américain ça fait un peuple oui mais il
ya eu dans en france il y avait le parti
républicain qui était l'un des
fondateurs de l'udf donc le côté
centriste ou libérale de l'ump peu ça
peut leur plaire et ses gains se
définissait souvent comme étant un
républicain il avait d'ailleurs je le
rappelle envisager de trouver un
changement et à l'époque où on avait
imaginé le changement c'était
rassemblement républicain bon mais ce
n'est pas le rassemblement
allez république il ya un autre nom qui
vous plaît sinon moi j'aimais bien ump
mais dans la mesure où il faut changer
il faut changer absolument
je crois que si on veut élargir réformer
les statuts je participe à la commission
de réforme du statut
si vous voulez changer complètement les
statuts ouvrir à la base et cetera il
faut aussi changer la structure et les
nombres de toute façon c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui choisir un peu au final
d'ailleurs vous emmener tous de vos
relations avec nicolas sarkozy comme on
recommande à vous inquiet comment ça va
non non non mais on a l'impression ces
derniers temps vous êtes un peu éloigné
de lui
vous avez notamment posté des
commentaires très élogieux voyez comment
vous êtes non mairie qu'on n'est pas
sarkolâtres on s'éloigne quand on est
sarko l'a attendu son avis compte pote
façon une phrase que sarko dit alors
alors quoi vous espérez sarclo réaliste
que celui vous définissez un
parlementaire et libre qui définit ses
positions en fonction de ses convictions
vous voyez vous êtes proche de nicolas
sarkozy quand même mais je les ai
toujours été et aller il ya quand même
des chances que les choses dures mais
au delà de ça je veux retrouver le boss
je les dis depuis un certain temps si
nicolas sarkozy si je retrouve un
nicolas sarkozy le nicolas sarkozy de
celui qui renverse la table celui qui va
vers des propositions révolutionnaires
celui qui ne s'enferme pas dans des
conservatismes c'est ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
mais aujourd'hui c'est compliqué parce
que comme il veut rassembler tout le
monde au sein de la famille il s'exprime
trop peu sur ce qu'il veut lui il
s'exprime plus sur ce que doit être le
mouvement moi j'attends pour le moment
je les dis clairement c'est vrai que je
me reconnais dans une certaine ligne
politique chez bruno le maire mais est
ce que cette ligne politique
correspondra à autre chose on verra des
primaires gibert on attend de savoir ce
que décidera
même pas une minute vous valez de
twitter oui et twitter vous vous passez
d'un clown des commentaires élogieux
sion penaud le maire sur tout le temps
mais vous postez aussi des des critiques
notamment à l'égard du gouvernement
n'avait pas du tout apprécié que le
gouvernement utilise hashtag de la série
politique
house of cards mais enfin ça comme ça
mais attendait qu'ils chef on compte des
roues auto alors mais voilà qui je
voudrais bien savoir parce que c'est mal
avec avec beaucoup les rêves et réalité
oui ça plairait pas hollande
probablement parce qu'on sait ce que ça
voudrait bien mais il peut jouer le rôle
oui